let's say that i have the matrix a and
we normally denote matrices with bolded
capital letters so i have the matrix a
and it is a three by two matrix and so
let's say it's one negative two
three
zero
seven five it's a three by two matrix
and what my question to myself or to you
if you're listening is what is the
transpose of a
and so we denote the transpose like this
a with this little superscript t right
over here and all this is talking about
is the transpose
the transpose
transpose of
of matrix
of matrix a and so your natural question
should be well what does it mean to take
the transpose of a matrix it sounds very
fancy
well
it is not that fancy all this means is
all this means is
rows become columns
rows become columns and you could
imagine when the rows become columns the
columns
the columns become
become the rows what do i mean by that
well let's do it right over here so if i
have three rows so let's be clear this
is a so one two three rows this is three
rows by one two columns so this is a
three by two matrix if all the rows are
going to become columns and all the
columns are going to become rows the
transpose is going to be a two by three
matrix it's going to be two rows the two
columns here are going to become the two
rows by three columns these three rows
are going to become three columns and so
it's going to look something like we're
doing that blue color
it's going to have two rows now and it's
going to have three columns so i said
all the rows became columns all the
columns became rows well i could view it
exactly like that i have this first row
here of one negative two i can turn that
into my first column now of one
negative two
i have the second row
three and zero that will be now my
second column three
and zero
and i have
this third row seven and five well
that's going to be my third column now
seven
and five and you could have just you
could have just as easily viewed it the
other way around you could say look i
have two columns my first column is 137
so my first row now is going to be 1 3 7
and then you could say my second column
is negative 2
0 5 and so my second row will be
negative 2
0 5. let's do another example of that
just so we really make it clear so let's
have matrix b
once again bolded capital letter and
let's just say it's a really simple two
by two matrix so it's negative one five
pi
and three are its entries
what is b
what is b transpose going to be equal to
well once again we have two rows and two
columns if all the rows become columns
and all the columns become rows i'm
still going to have a two by two matrix
i'm still going to have a two by two
matrix but we just have to say look my
first row here is negative 1 5 so that's
now going to be my first column negative
1 and 5 negative 1
and 5.
i have my second row here which is pi
and 3. so now that's going to become my
second column of pi
and three and so i have taken the
transpose all the rows became columns
all the columns became rows